[Music]
Oh in mother and son business news I'm
glad businesses in there cuz not porno
and creepy submitted by ready for summer
vacation oh my god her face a mother-son
duo have been accused of running a
prostitution ring together that's okay
no not even close it's still a business
that's no it sounds pretty tight
actually yeah that just sounds like like
Asian mafia [ __ ] yeah yeah oh like mom
had an idea and her son is loyal yeah
that's it it's like sounds like family
mob tight [ __ ] better than porno dude
yeah I'm just glad that they have a good
relationship yeah that's true yes mom
and son from California NorCal oh oh
what did that do to you I just pictured
it just changed like I thought
originally I was thinking the Asian
thing yeah like it was it you know try
and shave try it yeah and then when I
heard NorCal it all of a sudden turned
into two hipsters mm-hmm
hipster mom and hipster son well unless
the San Francisco Chinatown then it goes
back to the track hey that's true San
Francisco China with you do we have a
picture of them are we gonna play guess
that race again I'd say they are mixed
Hispanic and white oh oh the Chinese one
oh damn that was a good one I'll go with
what else is up there what else is up
there ah damn I just want to go to
Pete's coffee drinking people yeah Oh
Pete's coffee is a little different from
the Starbucks coffee
yeah which he's coffee I think are the
academic yeah like white people that
work at a college or something like that
yeah I'm gonna just take all white all
white okay okay I'm always five hundred
oh boy 4 5 5 I say white tea though
you're saying the American white
American white black and white okay
no it might be European white because
that's game that what you want
it might be what there is a rushing like
mob out there it might it might be
Russia really like guess that racist
[Laughter]
American white originally right hours
Asian originally I was thinking Chinese
specifically yeah maybe Vietnamese or
Southeast Asian not Vietnamese what do
you got Vietnamese me trying to go
Chinese Chinese 4,000 Chinese all right
let's do it
I was a mix Latino and white that's
interesting okay that's a very
interesting dude I'm so excited
who do you guys pick you racists
so they're being accused I'm gonna show
you guys in a second okay they're being
accused of running a 150 woman
prostitution I wonder if the race is
gonna change this get more details mm
Jamie you're doubling down okay these
150 I would have to say Southeast Asian
let me just give you a couple more
details okay whoo so the mother she's a
59 year old yang Zhou
all right mamasan it still fits the
Asian stereotype as a mama like choice I
have it up there and what they're saying
here is that she is a prolific Arthur
ascent author of feminists your erotica
okay it's white I'm keeping it damn it
the Sun 39 at 38 years old he would lure
the women into sex work and then arrange
appointments for them at three different
properties that they had and they would
cut the earnings very pimp like and then
apparently he would also get these women
into debt and then force them to pay off
their debt by like sleeping with him
we're like just doing me sick tomorrow
I'm sick tomorrow I don't know why I
don't know this
man could be black dude I wit with uh
with the whole like academic thing
behind it she's a professor or author
but but no black girl does your feminism
no it's not but like the pimp like son
no no so the Sun feels black but the mom
feels white Obama oh okay yeah I'm going
with that white mom black signs because
when I think of plot prostitution with
black I think like a pimp with like you
know like one yeah I don't think like a
woman's like running it I think like
there's like a guy with really nice
bright clothes and stuff what are we
working with she might be right white at
first I thought they're just two
pictures of the same person yo can we
get like a face swap why I find it
really where that the mom has such thick
facial hair I was not picturing these
people though that's so funny Matt look
at the camera I am looking at it no
you're not ma'am you got my voice down
to a tee she wrote a book about feminism
apparently plenty of feminist erotica
the woman that looks like her son wrote
a book about yeah that's so interesting
I'm pretty much down 2009 yeah cuz white
mom you got that right Shepherd that
woman has a black son somewhere yeah so
it's just kind of ironic here that she's
all about what I don't understand is if
she's such a feminist why would she let
her son pimp the women that's the irony
here I want to know she wrote so many
books what the what her books scores our
own Amazon
probably a star once I get it if she was
like somehow empowering the women by
teaching them how to not only control
like the sexual situation with men but
also like take a ton of money from them
how to monetize the [ __ ] yep how to
monetize to monetize out the book right
that is yeah that is for the book
extreme space of domination and
Submission handbook has four and a half
stars Wow pretty much yeah
four point four with eight reviews oh
they're probably hers and her reviews
the other books they have like two or
three stars it's only two reviews or
three reviews hmm yeah so it was like
actual feminists that read it like what
dollar pocket yeah this is like
anti-feminist she yeah especially
considering she was pimping out women
like is that feminism so that she's
saying the mom here uh-uh
in her jealous jailhouse interview she
said we need to stop treating these
women as victims they are highly
intelligent and educated shut the [ __ ]
you the point is the the son and
enslaved them through debt mm-hmm that's
the fucked-up part right and he's like
trick them into [ __ ] him oh I could
see why now yeah that fool must have
[ __ ] hell again he was able to
manipulate a hundred and fifty women he
has met looking like and I mean I don't
know any guy that aspires to look like
their mom yeah what the [ __ ] why is he
trying to copy his mom's style like cut
your hair and grow your beard out a
little did one copy the other or did
they try to meet in the middle that's
not saying the pictures page that their
business partners
you want to look like what an awesome
relationship right yeah oh yeah
beautiful
yeah first we were all kind of sold on
it and now we're like nah [ __ ] y'all
like yeah hey some people they have a
pizza restaurant with their family and
others they run a prostitution ring you
know I mean like that's Jorge some of us
don't get to do business with family
it's kind of sad the family business are
they hot cuz I feel like the underworlds
is not an easy thing they were caught
because of neighbors in the surrounding
brothels complained and then they
disagree so rounding brothels awesome
did I say that yeah that's so funny like
they have competition yeah hey their
business is too good okay that makes
sense they were complaining that they
suspected that it was a brothel there's
so much bleach around here the [ __ ]
these countries are blooming really fast
this year calm trees you guys know those
[ __ ] disgusting juice I know the
melody back
I don't know that tree though I don't
know those trees were developed in Davis
a genetically created come straight up
smells like cumin they do that how do
you smell become tree before when it
blew
sound like a very distinct smell like
but that's a wiener I don't know see you
guys agree all dicks smell the same you
do and I don't know what know from the
samples you've collected over the years
really look up country and you'll see it
you'll see it people look it up because
country's smell like calm and they
always grow them like a university and
all these things and when you walk by
smells like [ __ ]
it's always out of college why it's like
a white flower - it's very
this headline says this is why your city
smells like jizz and vomit every spring
all these are pretty yeah they're very
pretty they were all over what I'm so
[ __ ] funny something so beautiful
smells like something so nasty why would
they make that tree smell like comfier
it was probably like a scientist joke
I've seen this before yeah those are all
over Virginia hmm there's a smell like
calm eye when I was a child I didn't
really some reason that sparked the
memory I remember this girl in high
school she would put lotion on her hand
and she didn't know she was saying this
out loud she goes this looks like [ __ ]
and then everybody turned around and
looked at her in class and they're like
she goes oh my god
that's so funny
high school she just kind of like set it
out loud what she probably gave her
boyfriend a [ __ ] and said oh so this
is what comes looks like oh you know
what I don't think it really looks like
lotion by the way I think it looks like
body soap the white kind this is the
come into the playground yeah yeah all
right
[Music]